kann man es sexualstraftäter heilen und
sexualstraftäter nach ihrer klasse zeit
einfach wieder normal und unsleben er
diese fragen stellen sich jetzt aufs
neue im fall eileen wir schauen live in
einer pressekonferenz der polizei in
freiburg
frau franziska schäuble von der
staatsanwaltschaft freiburg
rechts von ihr der leiter der
staatsanwaltschaft freiburg herr
leitender oberstaatsanwalt dieter
inhofer
rechts von ihm herr franz sampling
präsident des polizeipräsidiums freiburg
neben ihm andreas röhrig präsident des
landeskriminalamts hessen
sowie daneben
wie daneben
der oberstaatsanwalt thomas burger von
der staatsanwaltschaft gießen in hessen
abteilungsleiter und dezernent für
kapitaldelikte
neben ihm
der leiter der kriminalpolizei direktion
des polizeipräsidiums freiburg herr
leitender kriminaldirektor anno england
zu beginn möchte ich ihnen gerne
folgende hinweise zum vorgesehenen
ablauf geben zunächst wird das wort an
herrn polizeipräsident franz sendling
gehen im anschluss daran er in hofweier
england herr röhrig
hamburger und frau schäuble dieser sache
in ihren jeweiligen zuständigkeiten
richten nach diesen statements besteht
für sie die möglichkeit fragen zu
stellen hierzu wird man mit einem
mikrofon auf sie zukommen ich möchte sie
bitten sich und ihr medium vor der
fragestellung kurz vorzustellen
ich darf jetzt das wort an herrn
polizeipräsident franz zenting übergeben
dankeschön aus sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich möchte sie von meiner seite
auch noch einmal begrüßen zu beginn
unserer pressekonferenz darf ich
stellvertretend für uns alle hier vorne
zunächst an die verstorbene eileen
denken
unsere tiefe anteilnahme gilt vor allem
ihren eltern den geschwistern ihren
familienangehörigen
und ihren freundinnen und freunden
die zunächst vermisste eileen hat in
ihrem heimatort und in der ganzen region
eine welle der hilfsbereitschaft
ausgelöst
und ganz viele menschen haben sich mit
großem persönlichen engagement
an der suche nach aline beteiligt
das polizeipräsidium freiburg das
polizeipräsidium einsatz und die
kolleginnen und kollegen der hessischen
polizei aber auch die angehörigen der
blaulicht familie haben alles versucht
um einen möglichst lebend zu finden
seit dem wochenende haben wir aber die
traurige gewissheit
dass wir einen todesfall aufzuklären
haben die
ermittelnde staatsanwaltschaft und die
polizei werden alles daran setzen um die
hintergründe des vermittlungsverfahrens
schnell aber mit der gebotenen sorgfalt
aufzuklären
insofern bieten wir jetzt schon um
verständnis dass wir ihnen drei tage
nach dem auffinden von eileen ganz
sicher noch nicht alle ihre fragen
beantworten können
der leiter der staatsanwaltschaft
freiburg r leitender oberstaatsanwalt
inhofer wird ihnen zunächst zum
verfahren berichten
sehr geehrte damen und herren
wie sie wissen wurde ein liegen seitdem
haben des 21 juli 2022 also dem
donnerstag der vorletzten woche vermisst
am letzten donnerstag also donnerstag
letzter woche 28 siebter 2002
gelang es dank sehr umfangreicher
ermittlungen
festzustellen
dass ein lean noch am abend des 21 27 22
von einer männlichen person in dessen
pkw nach hessen gebracht wurde in diese
person richtet sich nun ein dringender
tatverdacht
die fahrt führte an diesem donnerstag
der vorletzten woche zum teufel den
wetteraukreis in hessen
wo ein längerer aufenthalt in der nacht
zum freitag den 22 27 22 festgestellt
werden konnte
auf der grundlage dieser erkenntnisse
vom letzten donnerstag wurde am freitag
29 siebter
das gebiet des sees abgesucht
dabei wurde der leichnam einer wenn man
einer weiblichen person im see
aufgefunden
der sich dort schon mehrere tage
befunden haben muss
die tote konnte
zwischenzeitlich zweifelsfrei
identifiziert werden es handelt sich um
ein link
hier von haben wird die l familie von
eileen und auch die öffentlichkeit noch
am letzten samstag in kenntnis gesetzt
bei der am samstag auf veranlassung der
staatsanwaltschaft gießen durchgeführt
und gerichtsmedizinischen untersuchung
konnte die todesursache
jedenfalls bislang nicht ermittelt
werden
dabei ist allerdings zu berücksichtigen
dass die lange liegedauer des leichnams
im see die ermittlungen erschwert
bereits am freitag letzter woche also 29
siebter 2022 wurde die wohnung des
tatverdächtigen durchsucht
dabei wurden gegenstände aus dem
persönlichen besitz von eileen
aufgefunden
im zuge von fahndungsmaßnahmen konnte
der beschuldigte noch am gleichen tag
also letzten freitag festgenommen werden
bei den beschuldigten handelt es sich um
einen 29 jährigen deutschen
staatsangehörigen
der als jugendlicher im jahr 2007 wegen
eines versuchten sexualdelikt in einem
psychiatrischen krankenhaus
untergebracht wurde die unterbringung
dauerte zehn jahre und wurde 2017
beendet
der beschuldigte befindet sich nunmehr
in untersuchungshaft
zwölf tage
ist aline jetzt verschwunden seit drei
tagen wissen wir genaueres der innova
hat erläutert
wir haben unsere ermittlungsgruppe
derzeit etwa 150
bearbeitete oder in bearbeitet
bearbeitung befindliche spuren
werden mehr als 250 hinweise aus der
bevölkerung im vermisstenfall eileen und
bislang mehr als 10 millionen digitale
spuren bzw spuren fragmente in der
digitalen welt
wir haben mehrere
passwortgeschützte handys
und weitere digitale beweismittel
das gegebenenfalls zu sichernde
datenvolumen kann ich ihnen im moment
noch nicht beziffern
72 stunden
nach dem auffinden von aline kam es zu
der festnahme beziehungsweise wir haben
die festnahme einen ermittlungsstand der
uns auch noch vor viele offene fragen
stellt
eines dieser großen komplex der uns hier
beschäftigt ist die anonymität im netz
bei jugendlichen heutzutage normal
wir haben aktivitäten unterschiedliche
beteiligter unter anderem auch adil ja
sie war im internet unterwegs in vielen
sozialen netzwerken mit messenger dort
haben wir es leider auch zu tun mit
vielen
ihre führenden
personalien der user
sie war auch aktiv ganz normal wie das
zig millionen jugendliche in deutschland
tun im online gaming auf einer der
größten plattformen weltweit
auch hier müssen wir noch spuren
nachgehen weil dort jet möglichkeiten
bestanden
nach unserem kenntnisstand war ein leben
ein eher schüchternes nettes
zurückhaltendes mädchen
welches sich zum in ihrer freizeit auch
sehr stark um ihren jüngeren bruder
gekümmert hat
sie war so wie heutzutage fast alle
jugendliche in ihrem alter in den schon
zuvor genannten sozialen netzen
müssen messenger diensten und dem online
gaming aktiv
am donnerstag dem 21 27 22
nachmittags
zwischen 16 und 18 uhr berlin noch in
gottenheim unterwegs und wollte einem
freund einen hobby zurückbringen jeder
von ihnen kennt die entsprechenden
fahndungsaufrufe
nachdem sie in den abendstunden noch
nicht zurück war haben ihre eltern sie
als vermisst gemeldet und unsere
erstmaßnahmen im präsidium freiburg
liefen an
parallel suchte ihrer familie und
startete eine suche mit beschreibung von
mit einer beschreibung von berlin in den
sozialen netzen ich denke viele von uns
haben diese nachrichten auch erhalten
wir haben haben darauf folgenden tag als
am freitag dem 22 17 sehr intensive
suchmaßnahmen im bereich gottenheim
eingeleitet es gab dort schon erste
hinweise die uns zunächst in den
nördlichen bereich von gott in einem
geführt haben
bei diesen suchmaßnahmen in den ersten
tagen waren weit mehr als 150 kräfte der
schutz und kriminalpolizei im einsatz
und wir wurden hier optimal von den
blaulichtorganisationen
unterstützt hier für meinen herzlichen
dank
wir haben in den darauf folgenden tagen
von anfang an die hinwendung orte
kontaktadressen von aline soweit sie uns
waren oder über die zeugenvernehmungen
wurden überprüft
an dieser stelle möchte ich anmerken wir
hatten eine überprüfung in hessen diese
person steht aber nicht in den
zusammenhang mit
der jetzigen festnahme
es kam auch mehrere mehrmals zu
suchaktionen mit dem polizeihubschrauber
und suchenden in dem größeren
einsatzgebiet der kunden ist ab dem
wochenende dann auch etwas genauer
spezifizieren im bereich des tuniberg
höhenweges und gottenheim
die ganzen ermittlungsmaßnahmen meinen
ermittlungsgruppe also der
kriminaldirektion freiburg
hatten leider keinen erfolg
wir haben sehr schnell feststellen
müssen dass wir uns in einer aufwändigen
ermittlungen
bewegen was auch digitale spuren angeht
hierbei wurden wir auch sehr stark vom
landeskriminalamt baden württemberg
unterstützt und auch die provider auf
die wir zu gegangen sind
haben uns hier unterstützen dafür möchte
ich mich an dieser stelle bedanken
eine direkte ortung des handys von aline
war leider nicht möglich
wir haben hier an verschiedenen stellen
mit fragmenten arbeiten müssen zum einen
ich habe es während in gottenheim und
auf dem tuniberg höhenweg und wir hatten
weitere fragmente fragmente in diesem
sinne heißt das handy hat zu irgendeinem
zeitpunkt ein signal gesetzt wobei uns
keiner sagen konnte er wolle es handy
war wirklich dort
in der folge waren diese spuren teile
des gesamtkomplexes
wir waren hier in südbaden auf der suche
nach aline
wir haben dann
über einen provider an diesem ersten
wochenende einen hinweis bekommen dass
das handy unerklärlicher weise versucht
hat sich in hessen ein zu locken wurde
vom netz abgewiesen
weiteres hatten wir zu diesem zeitpunkt
nicht
wir haben die ganze woche in der folge
von den providern leider keine weiteren
informationen erhalten können
hier war aber sehr viel wohlwollen
festzustellen
leider hat es uns nicht weitergeführt
die überprüfungen aus der bevölkerung
sind leider auch
ergebnislos verlaufen
auch die ermittlungen im bereich der
möglichen sichtung im bereich
hauptbahnhof wir haben keine ergänzenden
hinweise dass er ihn am hauptbahnhof war
in den späten abendstunden des
donnerstags also am jetzt bin ich am 28
27 22
also sehr genau eine woche nach dem
verschwinden von berlin
nach den ersten ermittlungen in mehr als
zehn millionen datensätzen
konkretisierte sich dann ein bild auf
eine person in hessen
wir haben hierbei unverzüglich die
staatsanwaltschaft in kenntnis gesetzt
und es wurden von dort entscheidungen zu
nachfolgenden ermittlungsmaßnahmen
getroffen
ich möchte hier noch ganz kurz bevor ich
über leitern den herrn röhrig
denen wir können mittlerweile sagen
anhand der digitalen spuren das eileen
in einem fahrzeug
von gottenheim in richtung hessen
gefahren ist
wir können nicht sagen inwiefern sie
dort freiwillig mit vor wie sie ins
fahrzeug verbracht wurde das ist
momentan alles noch beim jetzigen frühen
stand der ermittlungen offen wir würden
sehr gerne zu gegebener zeit noch mal
versuchen zeugen zu finden für die
fahrtstrecke hier kommen wir dann
gegebenenfalls der berater noch mal auf
sie zu
jetzt darf ich über leighton auf den
henrich vielen dank für die maßnahmen in
hessen
vielen dank an meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ich gehe mal noch
chronologisch
zeitraum zurück die polizei in hessen
das polizeipräsidium mittelhessen wurde
am donnerstagabend gegen 21 30 von der
ermittlungsgruppe tuniberg
versucht hier eine wohnung eines
möglichen tatverdächtigen zu durchsuchen
wir haben daraufhin umfangreiche
vorbereitungen und maßnahmen getroffen
das wohnobjekt zu lokalisieren ist
aufzuklären und dann die
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen vorzubereiten
dafür haben wir eine besondere
aufbauorganisation eingerichtet und ein
polizeiführer bestimmt die wohnung ist
dann nach der abschließenden aufklärung
durchsucht worden sie liegt in der nähe
von wetzlar in mittelhessen
personen konnten zum zeitpunkt der
wohnungsdurchsuchung dort nicht
angetroffen werden allerdings haben wir
in der wohnung beweismittel gegenstände
aufgefunden die der vermissten 14
jährigen zuzuordnen waren zu verstellen
des aktuellen aufenthaltsortes des
tatverdächtigen den wir nicht
angetroffen haben wurden umgehende
technische maßnahmen durchgeführt
unter anderem hat eine ortung ergeben
dass er sich zu dem zeitpunkt am frühen
freitagmorgen in frankfurt aufgehalten
hat und es ging darum seinen weil er in
bewegung war seinen direkten
tatsächlichen aufenthaltsort
festzustellen wir haben daraufhin eine
festnahme ersuchen der ermittlungsgruppe
tuniberg
erhalten indem wir eben auch
nachgekommen sind durch umfangreiche
aufwändige technische und operative
maßnahmen und vorbereitungen konnte der
tatsächliche standort des fahrzeuges
festgestellt werden und daneben mittels
handyortung und verdeckte observation
durch spezialeinheiten der polizei
hessen auch lokalisiert werden
wir haben uns dann in absprache mit der
ermittlungsgruppe tuniberg entschlossen
aufgrund der wahrnehmung des
möglicherweise die polizeilichen
maßnahmen bemerkt werden könnten hier
das fahrzeug anzuhalten und den darin
befindliche personen die handelte sich
um den mutmaßlich tatverdächtigen
festzunehmen
die absuche des fahrzeuges führte nicht
zum auffinden weiterer
personen oder gegenstände
im nachgang haben wir dann
eine intensive
wohnungsdurchsuchung
fahrzeugdurchsuchung und eben alle
gesamte repertoire an technischen
maßnahmen zur sicherung von
beweismitteln in den entsprechenden
bereichen veranlasst und eben auch
durchgeführt
die auswertung des handys und technische
maßnahmen
sowie schon ausgeführt ergaben dass es
hier einen längeren aufenthalt ort auf
und als zeitpunkt im bereich eines sees
in mittelhessen durch
zumindest den tatverdächtigen gegeben
hat
diese
aufenthaltsort der wurde dann so
beschrieben und da möchte ich nicht
vorgreifen der vor ort war dass es hier
ein naturschutzgebiet ist so dass wir
umgehend entsprechende kräfte informiert
haben das heißt konkret wurde der
polizeihubschrauber eingesetzt ist
wurden kräfte der bereitschaftspolizei
als suchkräfte alarmiert und vor ort
geschickt und es wurden natürlich auch
taucher entsprechend
bereitgestellt
die erste feststellung der des
polizeihubschraubers als er vor ort
eingetroffen war ergab dann dass wir
eine eine mutmaßlich weibliche leiche
betreiben indem sie
ja sehen konnten woraufhin die kräfte
dorthin geführt wurden und die weiteren
maßnahmen durchgeführt worden sind dies
wird ihnen herr berger jetzt aber
darstellen vielen dank vielen dank herr
röhrig die staatsanwaltschaft gießen ist
dieses verfahren involviert im
zusammenhang mit einem sogenannten
todesermittlungsverfahren
am freitag den 29 siebter wurde ich als
bearbeiter von kapital sondern sachen
über den leichenfund in dem teufelssee
informiert das war am späten nachmittag
stehen ganz kurz die region ein wenig
beschreiben sie müssen sich das so
vorstellen das ist ein sehr kleiner see
der nicht zum baden geeignet ist er in
einem naturschutzgebiet liegt nahe der l
34 12 bei echtzeit damit ist ein see der
grundsätzlich nicht von personen
frequentiert wird der ist von außen auch
kaum einsehbar oder gar leicht an
fahrbahn
am abend bin ich dann dort vor ort
eingetroffen
mitarbeiter des k 10 aus friedberg
waren bereits vor ort sowie die
tatortgruppe die für
spurensicherungsmaßnahmen am leichnam
zuständig ist bei ebenfalls dort und
auch kräfte der bereitschaftspolizei
die bereits angefordert waren
um diverse suchmaßnahmen an dem see zu
machen in diesen fällen wird
grundsätzlich immer einen
rechtsmediziner
hinzugezogen mit diesem oder mit diesen
beiden rechtsmedizinern haben wir dann
versucht den leichnam zu bergen
frick hatte schon angesprochen die
leiche trieb am ufer rand und es war
zunächst schwer für die einsatzkräfte
die leiche zu bergen einfach aufgrund
der örtlichen verhältnisse dort weil das
hier abschüssiges gelände ist es ist
dann aber am späten abend gelungen
es wurde eine erste leichenschau
durchgeführt allerdings war es uns
aufgrund der leichen erscheinungen nicht
möglich die person zu identifizieren
daraufhin wurde der leichnam zunächst in
das institut für rechtsmedizin nach
gießen verbracht
die polizei
friedberg hat dann zwischenzeitlich
kontakt zu den kollegen das baden
württemberg aufgenommen und hat den
zahnstatus und auch ein dna profil
von aline angefordert damit wir da auch
sichergehen können dass ist alles
passiert an dem abend des 29
die staatsanwaltschaft gießen hat dann
noch in der nacht die obduktion des
leichnams angeordnet ziel einer solchen
obduktion ist
natürlich festzustellen wie die person
verstorben ist aber dass
gewalteinwirkung gegeben hat
die sie die obduktion hat sechs oder gar
sieben stunden gedauert im rahmen dieser
sektion konnte eine todesursache ich
betone bislang nicht festgestellt werden
warum bislang weil
die staatsanwaltschaft im folgenden noch
weitere ergänzende untersuchungs
aufträge
gegeben hat die rechtsmedizin also man
muss sich das so vorstellen dass jetzt
im weiteren verlauf versucht wird die
todesumstände aufzuklären indem man
toxikologische untersuchung macht was
man schaut als ob es beispielsweise da
drogen eine rolle gespielt haben oder
dergleichen wir schauen uns die proben
die wir genommen haben nochmal auch fein
gewebt ist also unter dem mikroskop an
und wir machen eine so genannte
diatomeen untersuchung das sind
untersuchungen die dazu dienen sollen zu
schauen ob jemand betrunken ist oder
nicht das konnte nach dieser längeren
liegezeit im zuge der makroskopischen
inaugenscheinnahme des leichnams so
nicht sicher festgestellt werden wenn
sie das spiel noch etwas näher erläutert
haben wollen kann ich dazu gerne
auskunft geben
der zahnstatus und die dna wurde
dankenswerterweise
noch über nacht an die
ermittlungsbehörden nach gießen
weitergeleitet und danach hatten wir die
traurige gewissheit wenn man dem abend
den dreißigsten siebten gegen abend
mussten wir dann bei dem leichnam den
wir hier in dem see gefunden haben
handelt es sich um ein
ich möchte betonen dass diese aus
unserer sicht
außergewöhnlich schnelle identifizierung
des leichnams und auch das auffinden
überhaupt der person was nicht immer
einfach ist und
auch die festnahme des beschuldigten
letztendlich nur deshalb funktioniert
hat weil die zusammenarbeit zwischen den
behörden in diesen beiden bundesländern
hervorragend funktioniert hat dafür
möchte ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken
[Musik]
ja
das amtsgericht freiburg hatte bereits
am freitag den 29 17 2022 auf antrag der
staatsanwaltschaft gegen den
so ermittelten beschuldigten einen
haftbefehl erlassen und der beschuldigte
der wie dargestellt eben am
freitagmorgen 29 siebter in frankfurt
festgenommen wurde wurde dann am
folgetag also am samstag 30 siebter nach
freiburg verbracht hier wurde eben beim
amtsgericht der haftbefehl eröffnet der
haftbefehl oder der tatvorwurf lautet
auf die tatvorwürfe entziehung
minderjähriger
sexuelle nötigung und mord in
verdeckungsabsicht
der beschuldigte befindet sich seither
seit samstagnachmittag in
untersuchungshaft
er hat schon vor der haftbefehl der
eröffnung gegenüber den polizeibeamten
die tatvorwürfe in abrede gestellt hat
bestritten mit der tat zu tun zu haben
und hat dann aber bei der richterlichen
vernehmung anlässlich der haftbefehl sei
eröffnung von seinem schweigerecht
gebrauch gemacht und macht auch seither
keine angaben
ja das war die pressekonferenz der
polizei zum tod des 14 jahre alten einen
die wichtigsten punkte für sie noch
einmal zusammengefasst ein 29 jahre
alter deutscher wurde festgenommen der
zehn jahre lang bis 2017 wegen eines
versuchten sexualdelikt in einer
psychiatrischen anstalt saß und der
offenbar zuvor im internet kontakt mit
dem mädchen aufgenommen hatte die
todesursache ist weiterhin unklar
[Musik]